it's widely reported that drones have
been used in drone strikes and I support
that entirely and feel the president was
right to up the usage of that technology
and believe that we should continue to
use it Barack Obama and Mitt Romney may
not agree on much but they're both
totally into the use of unmanned
aircraft known as drones to hunt down
and kill real and imagined threats to
the American Way of life whatever you've
got top Democrats and top Republicans
getting along you know that something
has gone horribly wrong
here are three reasons why drone strikes
are really freaking scary what is your
position on the use of drones one of the
main selling points of drone strikes is
they're supposedly surgical precision
rather than carpet bombing entire city
blocks to nail one or two bad guys now
we can just zap them without harming
anyone else and actually drones have not
caused a huge number of civilian
casualties but a new study from
researchers at NYU and Stanford
concludes that as many as eight hundred
and eighty-one civilians including a
hundred and seventy-six children have
been killed by US drone strikes in
northern Pakistan since 2004 we're still
a reports that targets get blasted
repeatedly to ward off rescuers from
helping the wounded what is your
position on the use of drones drone
strikes have been carried out in
countries with whom were allies are
against whom we've yet to declare war
they're the principal way in which
President Obama's infamous kill list is
made operational and yet nobody knows
how such decisions are being made as the
New York Times said earlier this year a
unilateral campaign of death is
untenable not only is such a campaign
immoral on its face it only damages
America's standing in the world
what is your position on the use of
drones the Federal Aviation
Administration estimates that in 20
years as many as 30,000 drones could be
filling the skies over America doing
everything from promoting local
restaurants to executing warrantless
snooping for local state and federal
cops that includes nano drones that will
be the size of a small flying insect as
it stands the taxpaying public has
basically zero information on how many
drones are being used by which parts of
government that's led the ACLU to file a
series of Freedom of Information
request to find out more about the
technical capabilities of drums and what
parts of government are already up there
in the wild blue yonder we need to force
the government to be transparent on
drugs
long before the machines start blotting
out the Sun for reason TV I'm Nicolas me
you